[Musique]
y'a quelqu'un est à quelqu'un pas à pas
il des semelles de grèce allait
appartenir à un breton à bonjour
monsieur bonjour monsieur art c'est
curieux vous avez une arête sur la tête
ah non là je vous arrête ce n'est pas
une arête c'est une plume avoir dirait
on arrête parce que c'est une pub de
poissons ou alors à fait possible pandit
dans ce qu'il fallait changer ou veut
pour la mettez vous à l'aise avec
plaisir
ac c'est une fausse barbe blanche d'une
vraie part expliqué moi que vous faites
pour la retirer si c'est une vraie
passionnée pas moins bidon je viens de
trouver un port là il sa part et vous
par hasard un homme non non ça c'est un
c'est un faux-pas ressortent info parks
a fait le pas quelqu'un qui a trébuché à
quand même soit possible ça fait
longtemps que c'est dans la région non
je suis arrivé hier soir en provenance
de londres
et quel bateau a su parvenir bateau
soulignant chemin de fer les traversiers
mais on se plaint de faire oui pourquoi
match extraordinaire on va tellement
vite je suis arrivé que sept minutes de
retard oui oui c'était un peu de houle
et oui vous et moi the do a brassé ou
canton de magas pas moi je veux dire
vous êtes natif doux à jeu suit lille
avec dc non suis là bas où ça là bas
el-adli londres avec milan nord de l'île
non je parle de l'île de france
l'ile-de-france ballon d'or je suis bien
puisque justin et en ile de france nord
à lille à lire il y lui comme rouge
voilà c'est avec 200 wii égal mais il ya
longtemps que vous êtes là et peint
écoutez si personne ne savait trois en
trois ans nous étions bien je vais vous
raconter sa vie la position en ballons
captifs avec mes parents en promenade
oui un petit goût alors le ballon à
survoler l'île oui voilà
et mon père a jeté du lest m'enfin ça
n'explique pas votre présence ici c'est
mon père était très moral mais bien sûr
et habituellement oui mais alors qu'en
ce moment pourquoi pas parce que je suis
poursuit par des sauvages et pourquoi
vous poursuit-il
s'ils veulent me sacrifier oui en effet
c'est pas drôle savait mais pourquoi
votre fille vous sacrifiez parce que
c'est la période des soldes à gaza les
potes la crise a marqué d'ici une
quinzaine ça ira mieux avec pourquoi pas
ce que ça sera la quinzaine du blanc à
bavay sa maison oui oui dit non il y
avait ce qui est des bateaux qui
croisent les environs abbas et tenez gas
16 ans il y en a un qui est passée à huy
alors alors vous l'avez pas fait signe
suscite sinon je l'aurais fait ils nous
ont pas répondu
si vous en dit ils m'ont dit et depuis
rien d'autre ah si il ya la semaine
dernière y en a qui est passé à 50
mètres des côtes alors vous l'avez pas
fait signe mais si non mais regardez
j'ai nagé dans leur direction et par
tous et sa remarque d'abord wings ah oui
c'est ça oui
et vous qu'allez-vous pas rester parce
que c'était un mirage mais en tant que
je comprends bien ici c'est pas
tellement touristes et va pas tellement
non pas tellement oui mais on parle on
parle et je ne suis même pas présenté
c'est vrai je me présente robinson
crusoé non c'est le le salève naufragés
lui même ben ça alors province alors on
va alors âgés ou demander de signer un
autographe à se dire oui c'est pour qui
enfin c'est pour moi oui d'accord ma
gueule non bah moi oui vous voyez vous
c'est pas forcément moi je sais que
c'est pour vous mais avec je dirais
qu'elles n'ont qu'à pas moi une
majuscule au guinness à moi moi moi
comme je me vois la hausse en juillet en
juillet vous ça dépend du temps bon et
alors et votre prénom et nom prénom oui
après ça je me rappelle plus en
guadeloupe votre prénom bah non je vous
ai dit quand mon père est laissé tomber
jamais trois ans oui évidemment oui bon
alors attendez voir quel jour soumis
nous il n'y a pas école mais je dis que
je dis moi ça fait prétentieux lui bon
ben là vous devez vous revenez demain on
fêtera votre baptême
ah bon mais comment je m'appelais
vendredi havas d'accord à demain et puis
j'apporterai du quoi c'était ça allez au
revoir et je n'ai pas venu et la chorale
qu'elle chorale la chorale bol mais
voilà qu'au ras le bol j'en ai jusque là
en plus en plus j'étais malade et vous
ou un rhume des foins rabaisse à la
campagne dans le métro dans le métro b à
notre dame des champs a prévu un docteur
il est jeune et quand moi mais je veux
dire ça il voit là je sais que matin et
soir il aux deux finales mythiques de
rome ita le midol n'ont qu'à changer du
lait en piqûre
c'est tout non à 16h10 deux ampoules de
plus vivable non aux piqûres
c'est tout dans le sens poussé de
comprimés de mai qui les augures
carabinée dans un verre d'eau non en
piqûre
c'est tout non 3 heures du matin une
dose de facteurs estime prospère en
piqûre non on en poule 1 et je ne peux
rien a dit qu alors ils veulent toute
ambiguïté un ancien champion de tir à
l'arc du sahara il est vrai d'ailleurs
je vais attraper un corps izard yeboah
parce qu'au départ c'est un rhume
d'europe centrale et comment vous êtes
on guérit en me soigner une fracture du
crâne
non mais vous avez eu un round fracture
du crâne d'une fracture du crâne des
suites de mon rhume le commerce car elle
peut donner une fracture du crâne
on est tellement près d'un mur si vous
rien j'ai pas fait le rapprochement moi
je les fais poser les coller vos petites
vignettes larry tu les regardes et tout
est là ses collègues cette vignette
fasse ma vie est 70 kg 210 voitures 70
avocats vous avais prévenu veut digne et
des mâtures 70's que celle de 71 m'en
sers pas ce principe assez que vous
soyez rembourser licence pro dj bien
remplie m'a fait du mal a dit favre a
pour être empilés rempli musique avec un
plumeau ou non un stylo à bille passé
puis une vie si vous vous levez temps
c'est un peu gros épaulard oui j'ai
souffert comme profession ceci
organisateurs de gala par exemple et
vient dernièrement j'ai organisé un gala
au musée de l'homme profiter au profit
des petites familles nécessiteuses à un
défi lancé par qui t'a par les bandes
velpeau a donc à vous savez comment vous
faire rembourser
bah oui je vais à la sécurité sociale
avec ma feuille de maladie mon ordonnant
aux mots il vous faudra l'autre papier
et papiers d'identité
ça j'en sais rien je mettais la sécurité
sociale pourquoi c'est franchement non
moi qu'est-ce que j'en porte comme
papier ont apportés qu'elles toute façon
ça montre qu'il vaut mais bien de la
bonne entrée à long terme de vente des
papiers dont vous entrez sans papiers
alors que j'étais encore trop faire
rembourser
ce qu'on demande par l'entrée en
truquant bourse à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur qui je donne pas ce qu'il
veut et demande à la personne qui est
non gradés qui vous appellera comme un
pirate est votre numéro que numéro
d'immatriculation dur l'appel kelly lors
d'appels en arrivant à l'entraînement
l'intérieur eka l'humour jaurès vous
aura donné à ben voilà bon alors par
exemple vous avez le 219 france
avez-vous concède une supposition pas ça
vous ennuie rêve des 220 non pourquoi
j'ai horreur des suppositions
bon alors quand on l'appelle le 220 hop
vous vous lavez et séchez debout je
m'assois il ne fait pas la forte tête
j'en ai marre et d'autre alors vous
allez directement vers 15 heures que
vous appelez banque est ce que lui dit
rien vous lui tendez vos papiers qu'est
ce qu'elle en ferait rien pour l'instant
elle tricote qu'est ce que le tricolore
ça dépend de la saison comment vous dire
or qu'est ce fait vous attendez qu'elle
ait fini son rang et quand elle a fini à
d'affiner vous tous et à huy pour
qu'elle sache que ce gars là de nombreux
cas lève la tête
ah bon alors je donne mes papiers je
rembourse 20 vous dit vous êtes tombé de
guichet alors je me rassois vous envoyer
chez 12 pourquoi ou 12 mois jeudi 12
comme j'aurais dit de cette supposition
je vous ai dit que j'avais horreur des
suppositions ballon vous allez vous
voulez agir à outrance vélo 13 voilà les
est fermé pourquoi ces fermes et s'il
faut tout prévoir
vous allez ailleurs les guichets ça
manque pas vous voulez vous aller au 17
diallo 17 et là on rembourse dont la all
i come on
préposé liste qu est ce qu on lit un
livre sur l'organisation de la sécurité
sociale
oh là là alors je me rassois non vous
toussez avons alors élève la tête je lui
donne mes papiers elle ne remboursant
les pas au courant mais pourquoi n'est
pas au courant parce que c'est une
stagiaire
oui la titulaire est titulaire et
installe alors c'est vrai quoi cela vous
rencontrez un copain qui retourne chez
lui je savais qu'il n'a pas qu'à pâques
est celui qui vous manque alors qu'elle
se serait fait comme lui vous retournez
chez vous ça j'aime avec qui il avait
passé sa vie je reviens un peu plus tard
et voilà et c'est fermé ah non moi c'est
fermé et 16h30 déjà à retournac dans sa
tour nord qui se fait maintenant l'autre
jour sur finalement demain le lendemain
c'est fait sûrement bon ballon ira soit
avec moi dans la rue ça fait ridicule et
bout d'homme alors c'est vrai non non
non je reviens un jour d'ouverture oui
mais avant vous allez voir votre docteur
s'est déjà vu aux y retourner pour
coiffer roman d'un congé de maladie
vacances à me servir ce congé de maladie
il t'aimera du temps du temps pour quoi
faire on vous faire rembourser
[Musique]
et du temps vous avez déjà rendu des
constats roger déjà rempli et constatent
alors vous allez remplir mon constat
pourquoi j'ai un accident ouais quand ça
tout à l'heure où ça en venant ici mais
grave
la tôle froissée france et comment dans
la tête de logan mais pour l'adulte à
des présidentielles à ce point là à ce
point là ouais autrement dit la voiture
est foutue a complètement foutue reste
plus rien de la voiture à 6 quoi le
constat mais vous vous n'avez rien géré
léger traumatisme crânien ou ça au genou
peut-être une radio pour avoir tel dans
les grosses têtes mais ça s'est passé
commente accidents laa aux vêtements je
voulais tranquillement marche arrière à
180 heures dans un sens interdit pour
aller me reprenne notre dame devant la
caserne de pompiers quand j'ai heurté un
convoi exceptionnel qu'ils aiment ma
droite puis je vous posais une question
d'en proposer vous avez votre permis de
conduire bien me contre oui j'ai mon
permis de conduire il fait passer avec
un inspecteur avec un inspecteur est
toujours en vie bien sûr il vient de
terminer sa rééducation
bon alors dit dont la roma gauche lâche
étape qu'est ce qu'un chemin et la date
de l'accident basso aujourd'hui alors
mettez aujourd'hui mais ça tient pas or
métayère bon le lieu le lieu la neige la
neige qu'elle 9 bat la nef de notre dame
mais qu'est ce que vous faisiez dans la
nef de notre dame va c'est là où j'ai
été approché par convoi exceptionnel
dans la nef dans la nes mon dieu avis et
scali l'archevêque envoyés entre les
indiens
alors maintenant je vais me tenait bon
alors blessé même les gsk des blessés à
ma connaissance non et l'autre
conducteur il est sans connaissance
après sommet nono edison a ou pas les
témoins les témoins et des témoins il ya
des témoins qui sont ils un mariage
parfait bon véhicule à véhicule b vous
êtes tombés ce n'est pas mon résumé
sophie d'importants reculs à voir dans
cette ambiance après l'importante alors
l'assuré l'assuré c'est moi très bien le
nom alpha le prénom remet aux alfa romeo
alfa romeo oui oui je m'appelle alfa
romeo free avait quelque chose monter
immigrés les norias devant l'adresse
adresse 1 rue de la pompe à 100 ce
numéro de téléphone 306 306 oui c'est
tout dans ma coupe et le reste ne serait
pas alors le véhicule le véhicule mais
la marque renault le type alfa romeo
n'entend pas de gauche par du type du
véhicule a justement le type de véhicule
c'est moi puisque j'étais dedans
non je voulais dire votre voiture d'un
cabriolet un break maintenant c'est à
couper numéro d'immatriculation n'ya pas
de quoi rire un jeu dépensé 4 points
qu'à ses 196 196 ça existe autant là ça
tombe bien ma voiture n'existe plus
alors dit dont la jouer demande est
aussi là pour les sociétés d'assurance
vieillesse cause est assurée aweys
l'assuré oui dans quelle compagnie à la
hugo y aille y y
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
l'assurance européennes et
internationales des automobilistes ultra
chic du yémen
et ça donne à huit points ça donne à oyo
y est comment écrivez-vous
automobilistes comme au torino mais 100
ans adacore et pourquoi avoir choisi une
compagnie du yémen
parce que yémen ma vie comme il l'entend
bon alors un peu plus bas un peu plus
bas
parce que j'ai même ma vie comme il
l'entend mais non je voulais dire un peu
plus bas sur le papier plupart c'est sur
le papier oui vous avez indiquée par une
flèche pour ceux qui voient mais ça
c'est fait ça c'est fait effet l'aca
était ce au début mais cela ne se sait
que toutes ses flèches vous avez été
attaqués par des indiens à l'ono mais
j'ai plusieurs points soit initiale ou
alors ils choisiront et la voiture on
était la voiture dans l'art est de notre
dame mais non se pare du croquis
d'accident on n'est pas ici dans la
voiture je ne sais pas dessiner les
voitures par décider autre chose
ah bon il faut avoir fait les beaux
après avoir un accident lors plus elle
est pas mal à l'aller en un peu fort
moi je viens rapport paris puis à la
pause yeux on essaie par les yeux c'est
l'essence avant et les yeux au centime
rien approche et pour décider les yeux
et préfète des lunettes
en fait je ne sais pas dessiner soutien
gorge adacore bondé gaza par an a batu
sauf l'allume-cigare votre allume cigare
est intacte ah ouais mais ça c'est
normal pourquoi on me l'a volé la veille
à 10 tours dans les observations la
caisse 15 juin ce que j'avais ressenti
ce que vous avez ressenti est un geste
que je verse en duo mais non jamais je
n'oublierai ce merveilleux hasard qui
m'a permis de contempler ce pur joyau de
l'architecturé de l'art gothique
flamboyant du quatrième nom du 14ème
mois mais c'est donc 4e arrondissement à
la mort vous signez c'est très bien dit
on encaisse que seul monde h tâche non
dash n'en voulait dire votre bonus mon
bonus versés par ouï oui cet accident
m'a lessivée moi oui alors qu'est-ce que
celle mon bonus ou l'échanger contre de
pâques et d'ariel bon après débat
maintenant je voulais donner mon courant
z d'enseignants non je suis conseiller
technique
koussa à la prévention routière alors
oui
de briques de faire un mur abbas ça
dépend du mur du mur à mur normal
qu'après vos armures normale d'un mur
droit droit oui comme un étudiant quel
étudiant un étudiant en droit à deux cas
l'auteur l'étudiante non le mur à mur de
ma taille quand même mesurez-vous la
hauteur d'un petit mur bon alors ça
dépend des briques de leur largeur
nantes en hauteur et la largeur d'une
brique ça fait combien environ trois
fois la hauteur
oui alors j'ai à dire à passer l'argent
mais [ __ ] en saut en hauteur ah oui
mais la largeur sera moins longue
et alors alors si la largeur et moins
donc votre mur sera moins large mais
sera plus au passé justement équivalent
faire ce mur mois ou avez vous appris à
faire les murs pendant mon service
militaire il ya des murs régiment en d1
1 kw à un mur et pourquoi faisiez-vous
un mur pour empêcher les autres de le
faire de faire quoi le mur
ce portrait clair c'est normal un mur se
fait de l'ombre bah non expliqué vous
verrez c'est très simple le mur de la
quinzaine étaient trop bas et alors
alors l'adjudant m'a demandé de
construire un autre dessus un autre quoi
un autre mur sur le mur trop bas pour
que l'auteur soit plus haute avant alors
en somme vous avez fait le mur pour que
les autres ne le fasse pas non je ne
voulais pas le faire parce qu'il voulait
pas le faire plus at on demandé d'en
faire un autre qui ne vise pas le sentez
vous comprenez non je pense me rendent
malade en tout cas c'est pas facile
d'élever un mur c'est plus facile que
d'élever une protestation
pourquoi élevé une protestation non j'ai
dit il va une protestation comme jordi
lever un caïman vous avez un caïman puis
tarn et du japon il parle japonais lui
non mais moi oui ou par les japonais je
suis en train d'apprendre
il varie c'est plus facile que le
chinois tout ça c'est des honda de
mandat d'un an des on-dit ique visite à
votre came en asie gâteau alligator non
obligatoire ali gâteau a oui ça veut
dire les gâteaux merci vous dit merci
autres calmants oui il doit être content
pays ayant mis là que quand il est
content non pourquoi pascal un caïman
c'est pas un chien comme vous le savez
vous il aime par dessus
avant ils mangent des poissons non des
fruits des bananes ont des murs alors
parlons mur qu'est ce que je disais oui
me disais que tu es pas facile d'être un
but c'est exact mais prenez le camp des
lambert par exemple qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait les lambent et bien ils ont essayé
d'élever un mur est alors alors leurs
murs et très mal est fait les gros yeux
il est peut-être trop mûr pour son âge
pour se faire une raison vous avez
visité jérusalem b embarque un embarqué
c'était inondées à cause de la pluie
non trop demande au mur des lamentations
enfin un vrai que c'est un monde autre
chose que le mur de berlin avant elle
avait visité ne visite pas un mais on le
regarde où on brasse en faisant
attention quand on grass pourquoi parce
que les murs ont des oreilles c'est
juste bon alors qu'est ce que je fais
avec mon mur mais c'est pour quoi faire
mais voilà c'est pour ne plus voir les
gens qui m'entourent que si vous en fait
je ne supporte plus qu'on se fait ça
j'ai d'une misanthrope misanthrope
misanthrope
alors si vous êtes misanthrope ne faites
pas votre mur en briques alors en quoi
en pierre meulière
[Applaudissements]
il aurait dû aller en vacances ailleurs
c'est descendu à l'hôtel des trois
marches non pourquoi j'en ai raté une un
bon alors vous êtes descendus à l'hôtel
de la plage non je suis descendu à
l'hôtel de la place ah ben je ne connais
pas c'est l'ancien hôtel de la plage
mais pourquoi ont-ils changé de nom
parce qu'ils ont changé de place ah oui
mais c'est toujours un petit hôtel de
deux étages avec ascenseur à ya toujours
des états où la censure a disparu depuis
quand big un client appuyer sur le
bouton du 6e le directeur a dû être
surpris surtout qu'elle n'avait pas
réglé sa note
voilà ce que j'aime dans les hôtels
français d'un prêt ça dépend des
directeurs ça c'est bien vrai ça tenait
un matin dans une chambre d'hôtel je me
suis réveillée au plafond y attend le
mandataire non un changement de
direction
c'est quel hôtel l'hôtel du parking
l'hôtel du parking oui celui qui a des
chambres et y avait du monde à l'hôtel
de la place en jeu vendredi au
restaurant il avait tellement de monde
qu'on nous donnait une fourchette à huit
ans pour quoi faire à manger plus vite
harry y avait un bon chef oui mais par
des ses plumes ses plumes d'un chef
indien un iroquois à woods usa comme moi
je connais un lave au point où on mange
bien à la fois où il était comme ils ont
moins de travail ils font restaurant
mais question dans le sens à vos
pouvoirs des purées ou des oeufs battus
en neige c'est bon non mais c'est propre
ah oui et vous avez une belle chambre à
l'hôtel de la place franchement bien
c'était une ancienne salle de bain
comment savez-vous ma cause du robinet
place à la tête du lit ah bon mais vous
aviez une salle de bain ouais où ça
vient ça comptait alors preniez vos bas
dans la pièce à côté
non pourquoi y ait pas de baignoire et
ependes robinet pour koné qui pendent
robinet chambre à coucher
c'est ridicule le plat servi dans une
chambre à coucher et mémoire vidéo
trouvez ça normal
enfin près une équipe pas de robinet
dans la salle de bain la question n'est
pas là où était dans la pièce à côté
quelle pièce jean marc bouche sur les
robinets chrétiens ordinaire la chambre
à coucher je plonge à la salle de bain
pour la chambre à coucher et pourvu
qu'il y avait un litige dans les lieux
publics est ce qu'il y avait une
baignoire et poitrine une baignoire dans
la chambre à coucher c'était une
ancienne salle de bain donc vous dormir
dans le lit d'hassan ii banon dans la
baignoire de sa chambre à coucher
mais vous preniez vos bain à l'hôtel des
bains ap comme ça et vous où ils
voulaient aller en vacances d'un for two
où êtes-vous descendu à l'hôtel du
berger à combien des toiles une une
prime et une grosse arrivée d'un petit
hôtel oui c'est tenus par monsieur
madame le sauveur et leur fils ils sont
trois pour diriger l'hôtellerie c'est le
patron monsieur joseph qui a construit
l'hôtel d'un bricoleur à d'anciens
charpentiers qui fait la cuisine
sa femme le mari et le fils qu'est ce
qui fait le fils va y sert à table il
fait ménage et tout jeune la trentaine
un gars très sympa avec des choses
jusque là une petite barbe le genre
artistes paper plus et les guérisseurs
et il est né le jour de l'inauguration
de l'hôtel dans l'hôtel non à côté dans
une étable entre un boeuf et une mule un
boeuf émules et non un art
mais comment se dit étonné dans une
étable abbas un mystère en tout cas
c'est la nuit de noël la nuit de noël
oui même que monsieur joseph a pendu la
crémaillère avec des berges et des
environs il hébergeait mais parce que
notre coin il ya des moutons alors qu'il
ya des berges à l'héberger n'ont rien
donné aux petits si un mouton haras en
plus beaucoup plus en tout cas il y en a
un qui a dit en voyant le petit il est
dit vince enfants bayon j'ai
l'impression que je connais vos hôtelier
c'est pourtant le sauveur ce n'est pas
en courant il s'appelle le sauveur
joseph et marie le sauveur joseph et
marie le sauveur oui et le fils ils ont
baptisé comment marseille lille et pas
baptisé pourquoi parce que ses parents
ne sont pas croyants dont j'ai remarqué
que vous avez de jolis boutons de
manchettes mais dommage que j'en ai
qu'un et perdu l'autre non le marchand
de la reprise pourquoi parce que je les
ai achetés à crédit
et alors alors j'ai prié les citerai
deux boutons de manchette de gauche mais
je n'ai pas pu régler les citerai du
bouton annonçait de droit alors vous
appris boutons de manchette de droit
tarifs restent à jeter obligé de couper
tout et mange rap de chenilles est
ennuyeuse ça arrive surtout que sais-je
psg devait acheter à crédit n'est pas
fini de les payer et non et si vous
payez pas up
il voulait après une déroute vous payez
votre aide car chaque pays est arrivé là
vous avez les deux bras dans le plâtre
que vous ne pouvez pas signé de chèque
mais si tard écrivent eux reviennent
j'ai parlé de bras dans le plâtre et
même été un peu scriptum haye
j'aime me casser les deux bras
malheureusement j'ai papier allait
claquer des vengeurs des blocs à crédit
parfois des morins combien de pages 50
payable en deux ans ou signer la ja oui
une enveloppe mais combien 50 payable en
deux ans signalant bien roulé un timbre
et bien avant deux ans est ce que c'est
une fille et n'a pas dit non au fait si
j allais ou simple va voir mon chemisier
clé de bras dans le plâtre
c'est loin en métro non à l'hélium et
trompait l'étiquette non les tickets
pays première ou seconde première
également deux ans parce que s'il signe
à la fois là bas comme ça vous êtes
contents de métro c'est pratique c'est
pratique mais ça ne vaut pas la voiture
qui aimeriez-vous comme voiture
n'importe quoi j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
ça m'intéresse la place quatre portes
quatre ans à cendrillon moteur payables
en deux ans que je suis là vous
fournissez la vignette et la carte gris
annonce à cet enjeu et moi je vous fais
un boulot biais de cartes grises
payables en deux ans presque si vous
signez là il ya de l'essence dans la
voiture près d'un point vous en fout pas
autant que possible cinq mille litres
5000 les trouvailles de les mettre dans
une citerne que ça confiait d'ailleurs
la voiture à ce moment là j'ai aussi
fait d'acheter un camion citerne
ça tombe bien j'en ai un vent de quelle
couleur rouge j'achète payables en deux
ans puisque six lignes là bas je suis
bien content d'avoir une voiture comme
ça je pourrais être rentré chez moi à 7
heures rendez-vous puis ce soir son
anniversaire fêté sacs des amis oui on
devait 200 mais il ya eu des défections
en trafic de banlieue
parce que avec deux invités y avoir
tellement l'ambiance vous les invités
commencent à vous avoir les invités à
crédit qu'elles sont invités jeudi me
reste un peu les vannes en une dompteuse
de harengs un ton de regret à 100 du
sahara a pas de gazon ça c'est bien pour
ça qu'il a du temps libre
1 à grigny sienne dans ce menu trois
intellectuels de gauche dont une jolie
un partisan de jacques duhamel tiens
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
vous savez le wire est à un employé du
drs
bon ben alors écoutez vous mettez
l'académicien s'il est encore vert où il
est à point il lui faudra une partenaire
la danseuse nue mais je souhaiterais la
dompteuse doiron et de tondeurs de
gazons du sahara mais je n'ai pas de
garde aux républicains s'y met à cheval
ça fait rien on était 2 c pour épater
vos amis danse pour emmerder ma
conscience
c'est tout j'en ajouterai l'employé du
garage et une fuite à mon compte est bon
alors je sens va tout ce monde a ce soir
chez vous 19h30 c'est ça en tenue de
gala
sauf la danseuse nue il ya vingt deux
ans puisque si vous signez là et voilà
comme ça vous allez passer une bonne
soirée prix je me sentirai moi un seul
n'êtes pas mariée non aux mariés je
connais personne volée une femme quoi je
vous envoie une femme à crédit et au
fait la traite des blanches un an je
vois des femmes par trail du cassoulet
comme femme quel genre désirez-vous
sérieux j'ai une sage-femme payent avant
deux ans puisque signé là je peux
l'apprendre conjoint vous pensez à
l'agent savage viendra la chercher avec
mon camion citerne à aix et d'entités
elle adore les grosses voitures
mais alors fait tout un crédit à tout ou
même le service militaire à part ça j'ai
déjà fait comme deuxième classe et peut
il refaire comme colonel pays avant deux
ans que ce que things signé là et
général quoi je me répète général à
crédit ah oui mais les traites sont plus
élevés là forcément à cause du nombre
des toiles avec c'est comme le cognac ou
du cognac non je vais tenir à payer
avant deux ans puisque si vous signez là
je suis bien content d'être général
pourquoi ça comme ça je pourrais être
président de la république d'avoir été
général président de la république qu'on
fait président de la république
directement weppes à retraite payables
en deux ans en payable en sept ans
pourquoi en septembre ça vous le saurez
que vous ça président jean fut rien
puisque c'est une pousse signé là bas
voilà une écriture qui le relie triple
nord voit à zut je n'ai plus d'encre ou
les devants si vous en avez je veux bien
rythmé payables en deux ans il ya la
retire
et donc oui vous avez fait votre
déclaration d'impôts vous
laquelle mais à celle de 62 alors je me
suis arrêté à 58 - pourquoi je me
lassais assez enfin vous savez quand
même remplir une feuille d'impôts je
suis humble une feuille d'impôts oui
pourquoi ne savez pas vous mais terre
c'est la première fois que je déclare
mes impôts mais les autres années
faisait pas de déclarations a beaucoup
fait jouer cette année parce que j'ai
gagné cette année je ne suis pas
imposable
il ya un fond et un net bond alors au
web aux chefs des départements
oui j'avais département arme était un
département avant mais lequel ça ça
dépend de vous si vous écrivez largement
internautes département coup si vous
écriviez ciré un autre département l'on
a c'est comme ça il faut que ça fasse
propres ah bon bon alors je vais mettre
un
un quoi bahin le département alain il
faut mettre son prénom nom prénom c'est
après façon je m'appelle par al
alors mettez var va la commune quelles
communes la commune du var vous êtes
n'aime pas je suis pas né dans le var je
suis né dans l'ain permettez brest brest
ah non non non non non non or il ya je
confonds toujours les deux forment ici
vous avez un nom au capital et j'ai un
nom capital homme était un nom capitale
qu'est ce qu'une amie
moi j'ai mis colbert colbert moi
j'aimais destin à l'essence et l'avenir
le prénom paul 6 pourquoi si ce n'est
pas parce que je suis le sixième d'une
famille de six garçons s'appellent
football heureusement il s'est parlé on
y en a eu 13 dates de naissance 515
non je vous en prie ne plaisantais par
mon vieux à quoi c'est une belle
victoire française donc c'est possible
mais qu'est ce que vous allez payer
comme rappel et j'avais pas pensé à ça
votre réponse aux mondiaux pensent pour
allonger mai 1937
c'est plus modeste quoi lieu de
naissance à l'exposition forcément au
parc d attractions nationalité alors
yougoslave par ma mère est douteuse par
mon père
mettez anglais anglais
[Musique]
profession moules marinières bon j'ai
dit profession je suis moules marinières
et où ça aux folies bergère dans le
tableau des fruits de mer
je skie moules marinières moi j'aimerai
vous voir un dimanche en matinée mais
alors ne venez pas après 5 heures parce
que je me refaire d'accord et il
apportera du persil s'aimer vous fait ça
toute la journée
non le matin je suis bedeau harry
changeait pas de couleurs maintenant à
mehdi bonnaud c'est plus un dossier pour
leur piquer bon alors ensuite ouvert
audrey carte d'identité pour les
étrangers n'est pas étrange vous êtes
anglais avec cherche à oublier c'est pas
une nationalité c'est un quart numéro
d'immatriculation à la sécurité sociale
moi j'en ai porte ça n'avait pas alors
je n'ai pas l'âme était un 19 12 1 19 12
dont d'accord mais qu'est ce que c'est
de dire c'est dimanche dernier c'est
gagné oui dans le désert tous les shows
sont tombés il ya une barrière au départ
bon alors à situation de famille c'est
très simple répondez par oui ou par non
pas c'est sain c'est banal
alors êtes-vous célibataire oui elle
vous marier oui elles votent oui elle
vous divorcez mais avez vous des enfants
non à une défaillance
ce jour là j'étais malade ah oui mais
vous avez des enfants adoptifs à votre
charge avait alors indiqué les médias
passé place mais mettez vos préférés à
lorient ramos et plus légitime
armistice mardi gras mi carême ça va je
ne mets pas yvonne non ça fait bizarre
bon alors vous tourner la page et lola
vous avez revenu imposable profession
exercée par jour alors je remets bedous
mais cette fois sans h riche mais intel
comme vous êtes engrais internat tueur
oui bon alors nom et adresse de votre
employeur c'est le directeur des folies
bergère non c'est pas possible je
voudrais c'est pas possible parce qu'on
veut pas être bonnes au folies bergères
ça même avec des plumes je ne pense pas
enfin ce n'est pas parce qu'on danse
tout nus qu'on n'a pas de religion oui
c'est possible mais bono n'a pas sa
place dans un lieu frivole n'est ce pas
oui bah alors la démocratie est un vain
mot on verra ça plus tard en plus des
trucs là maintenant mais qu'est ce que
je mets comme un employeur mois
monseigneur felletin
monseigneur enfin l'adresse ce g de
paris paris ils trouveront pas de toute
façon ce rez-de-chaussée alors envoyé
ensuite réduit indemnités émoluments ça
me touche et en 62 kg vous doucher en 62
27 francs anciens noms nouveaux jeux
raccords pour rien au monde et
brouillard voilà avantages en nature à
kessoua et me voilà moi j'aime et irin
du chef terrine du chèque oui à noël me
faire une terrine du chef alors je
m'étire une du chef à bord et ben alors
moi j'aime être maquereaux au vin blanc
va m'aider marois alors si c'est en
boîte vous ne comptez pas la clé mais
pas
bon déduction des frais professionnels
mais total des gains acquis qui n'est
pas japonais n'ont alors vous
additionnez les sommes touchées en 60 de
plus les avantages en nature
ce qui nous donne 27,3 maquereaux au vin
blanc voilà alors déduction des frais
professionnels c'est à dire moi je vais
18 pour le mon thermomètre mais vous
faites comme métier du mannequin au
thermomètre
pour qui avant ce qui va lâcher les
thermomètres pas vous présenter ça
commence sous le bras ah bon
[Musique]
bon ben moi je déduire le prix de ma
coquille de moule la coquille de moule
et la calotte de me donner la cadence
pendant qu'ici je dédie une perte de
calcium et et l'honneur alors fois les
pieds alors dos à dos d'âne vous allez
déduire 20%
oui c'est à dire 27.3 maquereaux au vin
blanc même cody de moules et une paire
de calotte x va lui faisait part sans
voilà enfin écouter j'y vais je me jette
à l'eau passé vous jeter à l'eau compte
hélas oui voilà ça fait 10 et 3,1 bedeau
au vin blanc doux est immangeable de
daublain que leur compte et vous avez dû
vous tromper l'arrière il ne faut pas
fraudé attention oh oui j'oubliais été
dur lesquels elle en retire des calottes
voyons ce que ça donne ça nous fait 17
francs 1,1 me donne une tête au vin
blanc
voilà voilà alors de ce total vous allez
déduire encore 20% ou encore avec vous
le demande pour le versant ainsi 10%
dames en blanc annoncée rapidement si
vous dans vos jeunes ajouté
on va savoir exemple et paris me doivent
trois semaines au valais à lancieux
bonjour je vous apporte mon téléphone je
préfère ma pour le réparer une marche
plus et où me l'apporté évidemment
puisqu'il marche plus enfin écoutez
monsieur n'apporte pas son téléphone à
réparer qu'est ce qu'on fait on jette
mais non mais non mais vous nous
téléphoner et puis on vous envoie
quelques intrus pour vous téléphoner
mais ce qui marche plus bas prix mais
oui mais vous téléphonez d'ailleurs d'où
un café lequel n'importe lequel tous les
cafés au téléphone téléphone d'eau qui
bat le l'heure c'est pas l'heure qui
écrasait c'est le mien mais bon on est
d'accord mais je ne sais pas vous
téléphonez de chez un voisin les vaudois
n'ont pas le téléphone vos amis ils
n'ont pas de téléphone
qu'est-ce qui vous prouve que j'ai des
amis orient lui dont on pourrait même
dire que parmi les gens qui ont un
téléphone certains pourraient devenir
mes amis s'arrête je veux mais encore
faudrait-il qu'ils n'habitent pas trop
loin de chez moi
pourquoi parce qu'il aurait fallu que
leur téléphone ah oui c'est alors
seulement que mon téléphone a déclaré je
ne pouvais pas leur téléphoner pour leur
dire que mon téléphone ne marchait pas
c'est clair non mais très très très
alors téléphone
vous habitez vous dans les deux sèvres
pardon dans les deux sèvres oui dans les
deux sèvres à niort dans les deux sèvres
ou de la boutique au numéro zéro au
numéro 0 puis avance at elle dit ce
médecin est tombée alors aussi vous
habitez niort pourquoi n'êtes vous
parlez au central téléphonique de niort
a parce que je n'étais pas un niveau
record je me suis aperçu que mon
téléphone ne marchait plus vous étiez
vous à paris dans le xvème dans mon
pied-à-terre alors ce téléphone est le
téléphone de votre pied-à-terre non je
parle de l'essonne a manqué de taper
alors ce téléphone bien doux de niort
dans les deux sèvres mai
comment l'avez vous apporter alors sous
le bras enfin vous n'êtes pas me dire
que vous êtes venue de niort avec votre
téléphone sous le bras mais si mais si
vous avez donc débrancher les fils et
les filles de téléphone enfin je veux
bien qu'ils ne soient pas les branchés
vision d'après mon téléphone d'un
baladeur non mais je veux dire vous avez
débranché à niort pour la brancher à
paris mais à quoi ça mardi le service de
débrancher mais ville de téléphone à
niort pour les branchés à paris tandis
qu'à paris c'est pour le téléphone mais
alors de donner ce fils à ce film qui
vont rentrer chez moi dans mon salon et
où est-il votre salon à niort dans les
deux sèvres wii shop vous savez alors si
vous avez vous ne me pose pas la
question que ces luttes enfin écoutez
vous n'allez pas me faire croire que je
ne sais pas où vous avez 400 ou 500 km
de files non non non non j'en ai plus de
5000 quoi we put jamais y arriver demain
je ne sais pas que niort paris figure
toi je fais venir madrid ni à rome niort
bruxelles tout dépend de ce que j'ai à
faire et toujours avec vos téléphones a
toujours oui j'ai dit je partais dans
mon téléphone alors j'arrivais dans les
endroits le téléphone ne marchait pas
j'avais la fin et vous vous êtes venus
comment de niort par le train et mais
comment faisiez-vous alors à pour le bol
d'air pour le fil lors je monte dans le
wagon de queue l'état mais l'enjeu l'est
se dérouler mon fils le long des voies
ferrées à oui mais bien dit que votre
pied-à-terre se trouvait dans le xvème
c'est exact alors pourquoi n'êtes vous
pas aller au central téléphonique du 15e
plutôt que venir ici à celui du xviiie
non parce que j'avais des courses à
faire dans le quartier saint marc et
vous êtes venu à pied non par le métro
avec votre téléphone
ah oui vous êtes monté dans le wagon des
gens non non non je suis venu par le
tunnel dont ça fait un bout de chemin
on se dirige alors qu'est ce qui l'a le
téléphone alors écoutez là tout à fait
entre nous si je le savais je serai en
ce moment en blouse grise et vous vous
habitants l'ignorent dans les deux
sèvres
bah oui oui mais rien ne nous prouve que
j'aurai le téléphone c'est exact bref il
ne marche pas vous avez trouvé les mots
qu'il fallait
bah écoutez je vais donner un coup de
fil personnel je vous en prie faites
comme chez vous vous pourrez juger un
bon prix c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux oui
j'ai appelé la province vous voulez 3
brest à 6 mois yves assez moscou avait
alors passé - yvan il va c'est toi là
c'est moi ça y est
magnette y est d'à haichao 1 n'a rien à
reprocher à ce téléphone monsieur j'ai
eu moscou j'avais même pas demandé mais
je ne vous ai jamais dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas voir moscou les parts non
c'est pas ça c'est au début quand on
quand on dit à l'eau il ya quelque chose
qui ne tourne pas rond
ah oui je oui
n'avait pas tout de suite votre
correspondant si si tu te fais pas
normalement pas normalement normalement
quatre à l'eau
j'ai une affaire vous proposez ne
m'intéresse pas de quoi s'agit-il d'un
pistolet à vendre et devoirs voilà c'est
un pistolet qui appartenait au frère de
buffalo bills à buffalo il avait un
frère ça j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
son frère d'un pistolet comme un
rendez-vous 150 francs
mais que voulez vous que je fasse un
pistolet mais l'homme de chevet merci
j'en ai déjà vu non je vous dis ça parce
que souvent fait les langues de chèques
des objets qui ne sont pas des lampes de
chevet que voulez-vous dire un homme
dynamique chez lui à transformer sa
trompette en lampe de chevet alors que
tu vas jouer de la trompette il souffre
d'un syndrome de chouettes noah joue de
la contrebasse
bah pourquoi est il une trempette parce
qu'une controverse est trop grand pour
faire une arme de choix à la balle avant
des mois une trompette pour faire une
norme de ce mec non pour jouer de la
trompette mais j'ai pas tombé davantage
un pistolet je n'ai quand même pas
souffrir d'un pistolet mais voyant faire
une lampe de chevet pourquoi faire jouer
de la trompette de soi dans votre lit
bon vous êtes fous ma femme kate jane
l'insomnie pas c'est parce qu'ils
avaient trop de café sachets mois une
voie plus de café depuis quand depuis
qu'on a fait une longue de chèques le
moulin à café
oui il s'agit bien vous avez une norme
de je n'ai pas de piste au latex a alors
jeté mon pistolet mais je suis dit que
ça m'intéresse pas non ça vous intéresse
pas ou que vous n'avez pas besoin d'un
pistolet mais je vous appelle vous
n'êtes pas obligé de vous en servir
comme d'un pistolet que voulez vous que
j'en ferai une poignée de porte
merci on a déjà une non je vous dis ça
parce que souvent fait des paniers de
patrick désormais qui ne sont pas des
poignées de porte
je voulais vous dire raison que j'ai un
ami qui chez lui remplacer soit une
forte part les bananes et bananes des
bananes alors que tu veux manger des
bananes il épluché poignées de porte un
nom et sont parmi les poignées de portes
dans les bananes la côte elles sont
mûres leur achètent des vertes et les
autres en fait il y les manches
ouais bah moi j'aime pas les bananes je
sais moi mon pistolet à eau mais enfin
pourquoi teniez-vous absolument à me
vendre ce pistolet parce que j'ai besoin
d'argent
c'est ça il fallait dire tout de suite
ou alors vous l'achetez norvège trouver
de l'argent mois dans une banque
je n'ai pas de compte patanok je
n'oserais jamais pour ce débat attaque
et 1 passe en attaque ah oui oui où les
mains dans les mois 150 francs mais
qu'est ce qui vous prend rendez vous dès
les mois 150 francs je peux vous donner
150 transiger les deux mains en l'air
alors baissé une main et des nomades 75
fois voilà merci
[Musique]
à chacun comme un dîner chez un ami
filochard et a pas de problème faut
regarder la télé la belle merci on part
tous les grands cris le père la mère le
fils pourtant ça l'esprit monbalen
cirque en plein visage tout le restant
du fromage en nous traitant de damas
c'est tout le mal qu'on puisse causer
tranquillement quand la démarche et la
filoche à inwi vous connu filochard à
brest pendant son service militaire dans
la marine
non non les chasseurs alpins changera
pas c'est pas vrai ça chamonix oui mais
après s'il attendait de bateaux pour les
ou à bordeaux à bordeaux il vend 60
vaches à face à chamonix à bordeaux il
ya un train direct pour chamonix mais je
mets trains directs bordeaux chamonix et
j'avais trains directs bordeaux
chamanique jeu mettra directement de
chamonix porté par lui elle était
possible et vous l'avez vous connu
filochard dans les mers du sud à mettet
pêcheurs des pauses il a fait ça
longtemps juste une plongée et après
apprendre la ranimer il est revenu en
france non non il est parti en turquie
ouvrir une boulangerie pourquoi ouvrir
une boulangerie en turquie parce que de
fermer oui c'est d'ailleurs là bas qu'il
a connu sa première femme à sa famille
turque nos boulangers un bruxellois
quelle bonne part aux élus qu'il
appelait sans cesse mamie mehdi dow est
il connu sa seconde femme
et puis en épousant la première commence
à arcis parce que sa deuxième femme et
la fille de sa première femme alors on
s'est mis les blues et sa belle fille et
sa femme est devenue sa belle mais voilà
c'est ça sa belle-mère avec lui sa fille
avec son premier mari
oui celui qui est homme grenouille à
volet méconnu non mais rien qu'à voir la
fille avait laborieux un peu grand art
on dirait un berliet je roule pour vous
elle est quand même plus joli que son
mari a parfois dire que le mari la
laideur dira clavier de piano mais ça
vraiment le clavier de piano le clavier
alors sans les blanches et le fils petit
fils le petit qui était aussi son appui
de beau temps
c'était fils sans rethel fiche que
c'était un presse-papier non non non
c'est un enfant ils s'en servent comme
rattraper mais c'est enfin là c'est un
repas gastronomique ce repas et
l'apéritif a regretté que j'ai la
recette vous avez la recette l'engin car
de cognac un quart de décharge nouveau
de benzène un quart de jus de tomate un
quart de limonade et un quart de bris ça
fait cinq quarts mais ça se voit dans
les grands verres et leur ensuite nous
sommes passés à table est tard que moi
je suis passé sous la table vous avez
trop bu ou à peine mais manque un pied à
ma chaise et alors moule à manqué de jus
par tomber fait pas tomber mais je
voyais le patio ne vois pas le rapport
c'est très simple une chose à quatre
pieds oui tellement qu'à deux ans
restait 2 comme je voyais tout ça
faisait quatre oui mais moi aussi je
vais doubler pourtant je suis tombé
parce que vous resté que sept pieds
lorsqu'on prend rien du tout j'en
commence une chaire quatre pieds oui
quand winehouse a fait 8 oui mon appétit
manquerait cette hausse est pourquoi le
pays qui manquent en compte par à
banamba pourquoi un big bang quand on
voit où ça fait de pépiements est alors
alors deux pays qui manque que cette
paix qui restent à phaneuf pied mais
j'avais une chaise à 9,8 bon savon alors
ensuite servi la soupe au pistou cote
mais non c'est avoir des biscottes
c'était des spontex base était bien
fraîche
et bien moi de la soupe j'en ai repris
non si sur mon costume à vous avez pu
détacher
oui avec l'apéritif à un résultat plus
de tâches non un grand trou puis nous
avons eu le rosbif france vive d'une
tendreté dans la bouillie ces personnes
je les mange et la petite cuillère oui
moi j'ai mis mon verger final qu'une
pareille et les petits pois rct du guide
était faire ça porte bonheur
alors on nous a pas servis de fromage
non les venu tout seul et nous avons
terminé par la crème renversée qu'on a
mangé par terre et c'est cette joyeuse
ambiance que cette soirée se poursuit on
le dit mot même on allait réjouit la
belle mère épuisée ont vu comme un
diesel e et piqué dans sa crème au
caramel le père la mère les yeux on
connaissait le suivi l'épisode à
solrézis c'est le mot table
c'est même un recond fiscaux zeebroek il
ment quand la télé match élèves filoche
à
[Musique]
lockhart tous oui au halo marie laforêt
est absente ans et moi ma rue du bois la
part de qui jacques dutronc est laurent
bessière
oui quelques ont fait don d'une question
à trancher alors jeune oui ici tarzan
est alors par son retard pour dîner
pourquoi parce que tarzan raté liane
8h47 à l'os et beaumarchais
non c'est vilain chirac et l'aunis de
l'intérieur wii sort dehors si t'es un
homme l amiral de l'élite car il a le
bateau c'est acura c ou un sous marin
c'est dingue lui raser alors on roule à
los feliz oui on puisse trouver hamlet
hamlet aux champignons
alors la spa oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quand un chien n'a pas assez à manger on
augmente sa ration jour merci je vais le
dire à mon maître et wej foucault est
ici blaise pascal et alors 26 poker ce
soir d'accord parce qu'un tiendre avec
des cartes à l'horloge parlante du mur
et l'heure exacte au quatrième tour qui
sera exactement 10 buts en 74 minutes
ah bon je reverrai plus tard à lomé sur
royer jaubert oui où en sont vos parties
ça traîne à l'eau presse parlait à la
dinde rôle est absent pour combien de
temps mille et une nuits où puissent se
joindre à shéhérazade
alors maréchal foch vous avez des
preuves alloway moiselle d'arc wiki qui
causent deviner saint-georges vous
brûlez déjà à monsieur charlemagne
oui ne quittez pas vous parle de
roncevaux j'écoute
allo pourrais-je parler à dieu est
absent à la passe et moi marc alaux
d'applis oui c'est chloé et ça tient
alors louis xiv oui c'est louis 15e
gagner à l'eau y circulent serrer le
frein à main le moment oui c'est jésus
non mais si elle est la reine série 4 je
vous écoute mon cyr le rabelais moi qui
a dit labourage et pâturage sont les
deux mamelles de la france c'est sully
les jeux même pas ou que je monte qui le
mirail
oui c'est jo ni ses bienfaits fallait
laver l'eau tiède alors que l'hiver oui
ici lilliput transforma d'armes à l'eau
l'académie française
oui j'ai parlé au secrétaire perpétuel
et moi c'est moi c'est moi c'est moi
c'est moi c'est moi
[Musique]
mes très chers frères nous allons vous
parler ce soir d'un sujet qui ne tint
parti à manta carreau à coeur à coeur
c'est exact un sujet devant lequel plus
d'un se sont tenues à coeur à carreaux à
carros est exact je remercie de vous
êtes tombé à trèfle à pic
ap voici donc ce soir des sept péchés
capitaux
c'est un sujet riche pas forcément avec
des capitaux et ses péchés qu'elles sont
il est bien dans leur nous avons
premièrement la luxure n'ont quà la
luxure dépenses investies capital signer
pendant l'ordre oui vous avez raison
c'est plutôt le désordre
non non ça veut dire par là que la
luxure n'est pas le premier péché
j'avais envie que ce soit la luxure je
n'ai pas envie non plus alors quel est
l'ordre est bien à l'ordre ses l'avarice
la colère l'envié la gourmandise la
luxure l'orgueil à la paresse ça c'est
l'ordre oui alphabétique mais ce qui ne
veut pas dire que si on commence par la
luxure aux soins analphabètes s'ouvre
assuré premier péché l'avarice s'il vous
plaît pas trop musique pour l'as bari ce
qu'est ce que l'avarice et bien c'est
quand un type qui a hérité de 50
millions nous avons de l'argent pour
l'instant pas avoir d'occasions
et quand celui qui vous propose de vous
louer pour y mettre vos économies y
compris la location par rembourser
l'argent qu'ils ont emprunté pour
acheter son coffre deuxième péché la
colère
[Musique]
quand un type qui a hérité de 50
millions de la vente de l'argent pour
acheter un coffret voire d'occasion et
qu'ensuite vous propose ou louer pour y
mettre vos économies c'est le prix de la
location par vous rembourser l'argent
que l'on va débrancher son coffre alors
la tête en coller à ce qu'est ce qui
vous arrive
une colère froide troisième péché l'envi
[Musique]
quand un type qui elle avait un sens et
dans la réalité de 50 millions vous en
prendre de l'argent pour acheter un
coffre-fort de cardio et qu'ensuite vous
propose de louer pour y mettre vos
économies y compris la location par vous
rembourser l'argent que l'on voudrait
qu'on a acheté son coffre
alors là vous avez envie d'avoir envie
dans le caisson sens des affaires
[ __ ] vous vous êtes envieux et
pourtant je m'habille jeunes quatrième
pêcher la gourmandise
[Musique]
quand un type qui a hérité de 50
millions vous envoie de l'argent pour
acheter un courant fort de castillon et
constitue vous propose de louer pour y
mettre vos économies s'ils avaient pris
la location il part vous rembourser
l'argent que j'ai emprunté pour acheter
son coffre ou 100 g avec l'eau à la
bouche qu'avec 50 millions vous auriez
pu vous payez de tonnes de profiteroles
500 kg terrine du chef mangerait bien un
petit bombe repas pour la terrine c'est
la gourmandise cinquième péché la luxure
[Musique]
honda 10 priorités de 50 millions
l'enfant de l'argent dans ce coffre fort
d'occasion et qu'ensuite vous propose de
vous louer pour y mettre aux économies y
compris la location pour avoir osé
d'argent qu'il a emprunté pour acheter
son coffre vous pensez les yeux
exorbités qu'avec 50 millions et que
vous payez sofia l'oréal alors ursule
andré landry raquel welch chela non pas
que les bas qui n'ont pas deux
c'est pas un mince avantage en a une
grande brune king kong
l'orgueil c'est après 6e péché d'orgueil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame mademoiselle monsieur cantat type
qui a hérité de 50 millions marolles de
l'argent pour un choc en faveur de la
cohésion et ensuite ils vous proposent
de vous lever pour y mettre vos
économies l'argent de la vente et bords
acteurs au corps mais vous dites que
c'est un pauvre type qui n'est même pas
sorti de polytechnique et gasol l'a
gagné 500 millions que vous auriez
placés en suisse
septième péché la paresse en
cultivait la paresse c'est être
paresseux être paresseux qu'est ce que
c'est être précieuse et rare de colère
dans vie de gourmandise la luxure et
d'orgueil
autrement dit la paresse et la mère de
tous les vices d'où le proverbe
telle mère tel fils à
n
[Musique]
eh bien nous a dit un jour pourquoi nous
racontez vous pas d'histoires des
histoires drôles bien entendu et car le
public aime histoires drôles ou l'amisom
marseillaise adore l'histoire écossaise
il goûte l'histoire corse il raffole de
l'histoire de fou voici donc ce soir
l'histoire de france autrefois notre
pays s'appelait la gaule et ses
habitants des gaulois tu leur prêtre
s'appelait des druides est révolue et
les adorait surtout aux bleus sur puis
vers les francs les freins n'avaient pas
de devises
leur ennemi disait volontiers le franc
ne vaut pas cher et j'ai le plus célèbre
défendu charlemagne fils de son père et
de berthe aux grands pieds patronne des
agents de police les croisades contre
louis organise la première croisade
ce fut en quelque sorte le premier
voyage organisé quelques croisé célèbre
saint louis pierre l'ermite évasif
d'arts croisés d'origine germanique
ça lui aimait faire la grasse matinée le
dimanche matin c'est pour ça qu'on
disait de lui il est très pieux bien
rire mythe surnommé ainsi à cause de ses
vêtements plein de trous n'avait pas de
cheval pour se rendre à jérusalem il fit
dû croiser est jetons à présent un coup
d'oeil sur la guerre de cent ans
oui voyons tous vu comment insérer une
passionnante ça c'est pas de la tarte
les anglais occupait la france depuis de
longues années mais une jeune lorraine à
l'origine brûler du désir de sauver la
france
son désir se réalisent à elles brûlent
une autre jeanne célèbre j'en achète
j'en achète était dépensière elle devait
fonder une librairie bien connue
aujourd'hui sous le nom de librairie
gallimard
et voici françois 1er françois 1er et
est très grand le principal adversaire
de france en premier des charlots qu'un
petit anecdote bonjour monsieur qu'un
vous toussez ici mais j'ai une quinte
carré d'art j'ai gagné et pour continuer
quelques dates au hasard 15 115 marignan
15 116,15 sans cesse quand je vois pas
du tout bien premier anniversaire la
bataille de marine qui était christophe
colomb le christophe colomb qui habitait
jeunes disaient je veux découvrir
l'amérique car âge n ya pas de plaisir à
son retour d'amérique il fonde avec un
camarade de régiment nommé kléber
fonctionnaires aux ptt une fabrique de
pneumatiques qu'ils appelèrent
hébert que l'ongle ce qui fit dire à sa
vieille maman tu as des goodrich
colombes gutenberg qui lui manquaient de
caractère inventa l'imprimerie quels
étaient les noms des six bourgeois de
calais est un jeu saint-pierre bismarck
à ce nouveau bernard buffet boussac et
bouchara qu ils devaient s'associer plus
tard avec les trois mousquetaires
profonde et les cent mille chemises nous
sauterons henri iii ce qui ne change
rien à l'histoire
et voilà henri iv tout ça non c'est une
image henri iv inventa la poule au pot
il fait en quelque sorte le précurseur
des potages liebig
mais il fut assassiné par ravaillac qui
préférait le droit qu à la mort dans les
cas de son fils louis xiii était mineur
et on ne sait pas si c'est dans le nord
au creusot ils nous disent pas on dit
que l'huître est ainsi de sa femme écrit
cholet april 14 qu'à son tour est un
petit fils de belgique à ce qui devait
bien ça va ça va faut pas confondre
marché et maternité je vous en prie ne
convenait pas voici donc louis xiv louis
xiv allons aussi je vous en prie non
c'est à vous dans cet amour
bonjour monsieur 14 l'état c'est moi oui
mais à part ça l'état c'est moi mais
encore l'état c'est moi et tu as assez
par mois voilà c'était une plaisanterie
de l'époque
après le 14 ou 15 après louis 15 oui
c'est sûr mais le déluge local des lieux
parce que oui 15 avait dit après moi le
déluge
louis saez est bon mais et tourne on
n'est jamais dans le bain comme disait
marc à il perd facilement la tête
la révolution française ii le prouve à
force de crier vive la république les
français est un empereur napoléon 1er
qui mourut des suites de la nourriture
anglaise
à propos de nourriture parlons de la
restauration quelques restaurateurs
célèbre louis xviii
puis nous avons charles disent qu'ils
seraient sacrés à reims avec ses grandes
chaussures quelles grandes chaussures la
vie en grande pompe
oui c'est vrai et aux fins louis
philippe à qui nous devons la conquête
de l'algérie
la première république nous a donné
napoléon 1er la seconde nous donne
napoléon iii à qui nous devons la
guitare prussienne de sedan et nous
assis sous la troisième république
quelques faisons waza passeur découvre
le vaccin contre la rage de rome en
colère et en 1909 blériot traverse la
manche au monsieur blériot comme vous
avez maigri mais oui tout le monde dit
que je décolle puis 14 18 9 40 40 45
quatrième république 13 mai 58 jerry
français et cinquième république je pose
waterloo et je retiens debré
je divise louis xiv par henry 2 ce qui
donne charles vii
vous ajoutez deux gouttes de louis xviii
une larme d'albert lebrun vous envoyez
le tout quatre ans en angleterre et ça
vous donne quelqu'un qui vous avez
compris zik qui rigidifie je lui ai dit
oui même s'il semblait bien maintenant
ça sent le gaz 1 2 3 4 des moines zen
chérie didgeridoo dès midi les guider
[Musique]
mais non merci mais non merci ça use
beaucoup ma guitare habitat anah pour la
chansonnette ça parfait mais pour le
récital
alors pour le récital vous brancher
directement sur un gazomètre genre avec
un masque t'oblige à dire n importe je
veux serrer dans mes bras je monte au
ciel comme un ballon rond au départ
c'est dans la nature elle vraiment
dingue dingue de bisous bisous bisous
bisous bisous bisous
mais si vous prendrez bien je suis en
transe vous êtes en train oui je suis en
transe à que la transe est belle
one two three viva a d'abord dit
tu m'aimes 10 mois 11 mois 12 mois un
nom
joyeux anniversaire et un petit beurre
c'est pour you happy birthday to you par
un petit beurre c'est pour you et ils
préfèrent les petits beurre quand on ne
connaît pas une langue on sert pas la
sienne pour parler celle des autres
nouvelles ça vous me verrez par lettre
recommandée tropicale irene à bord de
quads ou la la quel rythme j'ai glissé
au goitschel je veux te serrer au creux
de mes bras je monte au ciel comme un
ballon rouge raf au départ cela bouge
ces voitures est vraiment tu prends la
vie comme un souverain ou bisous bisous
bisous ne l'a pas remettre ça et grosses
bises ou bisous ballon je fais mon seul
autre tombeau attention one 2 three 4 et
voilà vous aimez c'est à dire qu'il ya
un passage qui m'a échappé
voulant jouer oil 2 6 4 et encore gens
sautent hors c'est insolite
sachant que c'était un solo est un solo
insolite arrive d'ailleurs le titre
insolite solo avant mais c'est le style
rock quirke empire avec deux grands
tiroirs le dessus en marre des titres
colonnes de chaque côté saveurs riches
avec l'empereur et la musique est
entièrement de vouvant entièrement non
non on joue à la wii j'ai emprunté à
massenet aubry quand dans werther oui le
barça joue werther dia charlotte ich
liebe dich abers flou butane
ce qui veut dire je t'aime mais ça sent
le gaz un sérum anti sano s'écoutant ya
eye-fi drive
[Musique]
complètement fou table et surtout de
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont ça fait longtemps que travailler
ici vous ça fait 7 en 1h10 pourquoi il
dit avant maison je suis arrivé j'avais
une nordiste davance haye vouliez faire
bonne impression
non mais avait comme du métro car vous
êtes venu en taxi non à pied et à pied
est arrivé avec une heure d'avancé
j'habite à 50 mètres l'abonné ou en
métro parce que c'est direct ah oui
alors c'est fait c'est top
vous connaissez le patron monsieur
marcel allons avancer pas mais je
versais c'était monsieur vladimira
s'était pas monsieur marseille ans à
monsieur vladimir stepanov a annoncé
vérité monsieur marcel job j'aurais pas
prononcé de la limite mais c'était un
parent monsieur marcel est le beau-père
monsieur marcel à celle bufera michel
gombert monsieur marcel sabourin
et alors c'est lui qui a ouvert la boîte
rue on me soucier toute une histoire
figurez-vous je me figure un soir
monsieur vladimir vos folies bergère oui
il en sort ébloui par les plumes quel
point les plumes des danseuses des
folies bergère ah oui alors alors il a
acheté une vingtaine d'autres ruches et
un stock de riz matin pourquoi faire les
réveille matin
ben pour donner à manger aux autruches à
ryad la cour bref bref il a vendu ses
plumes aux folies bergères il a fait
fortune lâcher ce cas pareil mais dit
monsieur marcel à lui il était le métier
aussi en nombre du tout alors qu'ils
étaient fer blanc tirage nisr fer blanc
car johnny se faisaient des passes vers
9 avec des vieilles casseroles
mais comment at il rencontré la fille à
monsieur vladimir alors là c'est une
merveilleuse histoire d'avant
figurez-vous je figure marceline la
fille de monsieur vladimir avait des
taches de son nouvel étage de son coin
des taches de rousseur à des tâches de
son oui c'est ça son vivant elle avait
pris le soleil à travers une passoire
bas révèle exacte hier c'est ce qu'il a
connu maria un long dont messi parce que
marceline était désolé de ses tâches et
monsieur marcel a trouvé le moyen de les
faire disparaître les efface en tenons
en en rajoutant d'autres à sa joie pas
c'est très simple monsieur marcel a pris
une passoire
il a posé son visage de mars o'neal en
plein soleil mais comment at il fait
pour ajouter des tâches en déplaçant les
trous de la passoire
et à part ça vous êtes passé un bon
dimanche ah oui j'étais au cinéma et
votre fiancée marek mon poisson rouge
ouais ça lui a plu bon du tout qu'est-ce
qu'on joue un pêcheur d'islande
il a pas aimé non d'un truc c'était un
film raciste c'est un cadeau aux
poissons berry vie de mon père adoptif à
vous est orphelin de père
non c'est mon père adoptif qui était
orphelin fils s'est alors alors j'ai
adopté un baby boomer que dit votre
vraie paix mon vrai père votre pape il a
disparu il ya longtemps il ya dix ans le
jour où ma mère lui dit alexandrowicz il
s'appelle alexandre urwicz nom jules
alors pourquoi la blade alexandrowicz
parce qu'elle n'a pas la mémoire des
prénoms en soirée bon les hymnes à
rémois voulez vous je vous narre hainard
et ma mère lui dit alexandrowicz va me
chercher du beurre pour faire la cuisine
et alors alors il n'est jamais revenu
les cafés maintenant votre mère est là
faire la cuisine à l'huile
ah oui mais quand même ça a dû vous
faire un coup bah oui parce que je
m'étais habitué au beurre et votre frère
ce qu'ils jouent aux dames
celui qui jouait d'amis les pions dans
un collège a remarqué comme dit mon
frère aîné à moi le principal dans la
vie c'est la santé très bien fait ce
qu'est ce qui fait autre frère aîné il y
est bon il ya parce qu'elle est gentille
votre frère aîné tiburce il a 63 ans 63
ans 63 titi a quand même mais oui à
force mais quel âge a donc à votre mère
50 ans
mais enfin comment peut-elle avoir un
fils de 63 ans est impossible c'est ce
que je me tue les invités depuis des
années et que dit à elle elle dit rien
c'est son préféré mais les autres
françois marie françoise et celles qui
travaillent aux abattoirs à nos matins
elle est esthéticienne
oui elle a fini sur l'apprentissage
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait comme études
pour sa science po ah oui c'était ça ou
les mines et autres se reflète à flavie
lors je vous arrête flavie le masseur
flavier ma demi soeur
depuis quand de vie égale un accident
d'avion par contre c'est comme ma soeur
ma vie celle qui épouse et un capitaine
on sait la cadette c'est l'axé la cada
et qu'est ce qu'il est devenu le
capitaine garde des sceaux garde des
sceaux où ça dans un poste à l'essence
sur l'autoroute alors pour on faisait
comme basse et ça marche ça roule alors
pour viser comme ma positon fait douce
avec je suis très ennuyé parce que j'ai
un oncle qui a pris l'autobus se connaît
les tant de gens qui prennent l'autobus
mais pas en pleine poitrine
oui à penser comme ma soeur d'alona au
fait combien chez vous on est onze
depuis hier une naissance bonne visite
une visite lesquels is it un berger
allemand
alors vous êtes dit c'est un chien quel
chien
berger allemand est pas un chien un
berger allemand c'est pas un chien un
berger allemand est un berger allemand
commis à l'héberger français c'est un
pâtre c'est un patron c'est ça oui je ne
savais pas le dire en allemand alors
pour renverser comme ma soeur on ne dit
pas arrivé de votre famille ce berger
allemand ils sont cousins germains oui
alors pesé comme ma soeur c'est comme ma
soeur commencé m'énerver qu'est ce
qu'elle à votre insu rien c'est mon
frère voiture c'est votre vrai nom mon
frère a trouvé dray comme ma soeur
étaient au chômage au dessus enfin sur
mon frère est alors il a trouvé un
emploi a pris comme ma soeur et que
fait-elle votre laquelle eva celle qui a
trouvé un nom plus commode frères
parfois mal mon frère est pourquoi me
dit tout sans arrêt c'est comme ma soeur
c'est comme un soir mon frère a trouvé
du travail
ça consiste en quoi son travail il mas i
mas mais alors il est ma soeur mais les
taupes tu sais pas si tu es un grand
malade mais la soeur 12 me parliez pas
oui passer cette question dans bull a
annoncé récemment bilal et plus elle est
guérie elle est tombée
on va regarder le sud là où va-t-il
servir mon pays va vite
en vérité les chansons au piano fender
d'appartements à vendre les genres la
skull un masculin est une garçonnière
c'est à quel étage temps 9e et à combien
dedaj 8,8 à temps on s'est dit que
habito ne viennent pas toujours d'être
dérangé sega de forcer la porte de
gauche mais avoir mentionné la porte de
phase iia deux entraînements il accule
la porte à gauche alors que vous dites
que je sonne à la porte de fass ouvrir
voilà vous savez je vous aurez vous
entrez dans le vestibule dans la salle
de bain y'a pas de vestibule de
l'échangé entre quoi contre une salle de
bains elle est grande salle de bains que
m sur 1 sur un couac sur un tapis de sol
et après la salle de bain alors le
gymnase le gym d'art à cinq n'a pas de
stade dont j'attendais une subvention
gpu n'avait pu des retraités souffert
dans ce gymnase gymnastique
non c il est grand à mettre sur deux en
main sur deux ans ginette un carton à
chaussures quand c'est possible mais
quelle belle pointure des donc c'est au
plafond un maître un maître que ce qu'on
veut bien faire dans un gymnase d'un
mètre de haut les abdominaux
là c'est vrai j'ai pas française mais
comment se fait-il que ce soit si bas de
plafond
alors parce que vous avez le living room
with the living room mesure 1 mètre sur
deux je suppute allons là vous supputer
de travers ce livre nous faisons
exactement 15 mètres sur 18 ha bah voilà
enfin une caisse confortable on peut
recevoir des amis non c'est impossible
pourquoi elles étant compris encombré de
quoi de caisse de kate sait de quel jeu
fait d'exportations exportations de quoi
de caisse
cristiano voces et petites caisses
l'histoire des petites pièces dans les
moyennes qui ne fait pas la grosse tête
sans moi mon oncle poussa au concert par
de l'eau ah oui un seul bijou de la
grosse caisse à pas de loup il s'amuse
en vie alors à gauche dans le fauteuil 0
vous avez une porte qui donne sur le
fils a pas ce qu'est un office à vous
tous les dimanches et à droite une porte
qui donne sur la rue sur la rue sur la
rue du neuvième d'une objets abati temps
ça fait une grande marche assez grands
et petits qui donne sur la rue
mais avant elle donne accès la cuisine
mais j'ai mordu la cuisine acquis à des
étrangers que l'idée reprend tellement
vous êtes bien que les étrangers adore
la cuisine française
et où manger vous une petite pièce et où
dormez-vous dans une grande pièce qu'est
ce que c'est drôle
un nom revient du gange d'absolument me
débarrasser de celui non mais mes
caisses mais votre exportations restons
mais j'aime par-dessus la tête qu'est ce
que vous allez faire maintenant de
l'importation l'importation de coin de
planches pour quoi faire
les caisses voyez pas mon vieux votre
immigrent m'intéresse avec us en caisse
avec les caisses ce sont les caisses qui
m'intéresse à vous faites aussi dans la
caisse non moi je suis dans le coin en
coin dans quel coin n'importe quel coin
n'importe quel coin là quoi ça vous
étonne donc quelle sorte de coin mais
tous les coins le fou est en général
quel fruit mal à cohabiter dans le point
médian par le coin le fruit le coin coin
à le coin coin oui des klaxons
mais non le coin rega c'est que c'est
quoi bon donner par exemple ce moment je
travaille avec la sncf oui je leur vends
des couloirs adéquat peut-être le coin
voilà je l'aï compris le coin et vous ne
savez qu'avec la sncf
non non non je fais tous les coins
traite pas les roquois n'ont jamais de
répit qu'est ce que vous faites de votre
coin et bien comme quoi je fais le coin
de rue ou quoique piscine et 80 pour les
enfants fait pas le petit coin non trop
de concurrence mais par contre je fais
le petit marché à cet intérêt solution
en ce moment sont hors de prix oui mais
longtemps vous êtes notre de père en
fils ça vous plaît tu nord mes parents
m'ont forcée qu'auriez vous aimé fait
j'aurais voulu être là mme andré gide
bar de la rue baron n'ont pas voulu non
c'est elle on m'a dit donne moi j'ai une
affaire vous proposez vous explique au
lieu de mende mégajoule en mai coin quel
coin se décoince n'est qu'à 6 par free
mais vous n'aurez plus qu est ce parce
que son coin porte casse nommé genres et
des planches et lieusaint d'importation
et d'exportation
et ben moi j'ai une meilleure affaire
vous proposez vous écoute vous gardez
vos planches pour faire des quêtes alors
là j'ai une proposition à vous faire
avec les planches qui moi je leur fais
des quêtes
j'achète beaucoup il reste des plongeurs
fait des pièces qui dit qu'un petit coin
pour acheter vos coins dix mois des
plongeurs fait lesquels je vous achète
vos coin j'en fais des cafés ainsi de
suite voilà quand on aura plus de
caisses à bord changera de quoi demander
la carte du magasin du festival north
hero et et je travaille moi je dis que
je travaille dur
donc oui on sait pas où je pourrais
trouver les boules par hasard
des boules par hasard met les boules par
hasard oui mais absolument ce soit des
boules par hasard alors pas forcément
mais comme c'est introuvable si vous en
trouvez ce sera sûrement par hasard
c'est introuvable aurait du mal entouré
plusieurs j'aimerais plusieurs sans
aucune alors pourquoi nous demander si
vous connaissez un endroit où vous
trouvez des boules parce qu'un endroit
où il ya des boules c'est qu'un à
plusieurs et alors il y en a plusieurs
je pourrais en trouver une
bien sûr quelques jours de boules
cherchez-vous une boule ronde ronde
ronde
c'est un antiquaire en mai chez des
antiquaires et non des boules d'époque
ah oui vous n'aimez pas la boule
d'époque ici j'aime bien la boule
d'époque enfin je cherche plutôt à
boncourt en tout huit boules la commune
à saissac oulabou d'escalier par exemple
marquant fragile pas d'escalier chez moi
alors comment faites-vous pour monter
chez vous quand l'ascenseur dans
l'ascenseur est en panne
d'autres ont leur épargne en avant le
rôle réparé que cherche une boule ah oui
c'est vrai oui que pensez-vous de la
boule qui roule en boule qui roule la
boule de pétanque alors l'honore je ne
veux pas de boules amusante à ou
préfèrent la boule sérieuse plus tôt
jean bonne boule de la fta lynch wazir
je préfère la boule de gomme oui mais
bulldogs n'est pas efficace contre
limite aussi mais elle est comestible à
usain bolt qui se mange non pas du tout
pas du tout je voudrais une boule qui
durent bull qui dure inutile de parler
de la boule de neige soit inutilisable
en été après moussa c'est une boule pour
l'été a non je voudrais le double qui me
fasse au moins toute l'année ça vous
suffit bas en principe oui pourquoi
principe a parfois on sait ce que ça se
passe
louis vachon en 2001 quand t'as bu
l'ordinaire pour quoi faire comme quoi
c'est l'ordinaire et brassac en sable et
alors et alors on attend entre une haute
ordinaire vous avez des avis oui mais
alors pour ça il faut acheter de boulot
il faut deux boules mais ben non merci
j'ai déjà assez mal en trouver même si
vous disiez pourquoi vous offre une
boule saavedra et voilà c'est pour
remplacer celle que j'ai cassé a donc
vous en aviez d'une oui oui j'en avais
une c'est un ami qui me l'avait offert
et vous l'avez et il a trouvé cette
année chez un marchand de mort soit de
quoi la marchande bull m'a demandé à
votre ami l'adresse du marchand bolt
n'est plus de ce monde qu'ils
marchandent bull non mon ami
les marchandes bull n'est plus en france
où est-il en bulgarie bigre ça s'arrange
pas non surtout que cet accord qui a
plus de boules en france en octobre pour
la saison déboule enfin je ne sais pas
tourné avec le marché commun va pas
jusqu'au bord huit hommes avez vous
songé au goût étrange être oui mais les
bulls étrangères n'ont pas dit je ne
sais quoi qui caractérisait bull
français ce même les bulldozers
continuent à peser lourd nous allons
permettre à vous dire que question bulls
est difficile toile enchères contre et
amateurs de boules en croit pas
n'importe quel boulot mais encore
faudrait-il savoir l'utilité de cette
boule assez fort chez moi c'est pour
chez vous c'est pour chez moi donc j'ai
des boules intérieur c'est ça c'est ça
une boule d'intérieur mais qu'on puisse
sortir
oui la boule familiale en quelques
sortes le groupe familial ou individuels
tout dépend la façon dont on s'en sert
comptez vous en servir souvent chaque
fois que j'en aurai besoin oui allons
somme si j'ai bien compris c'est
davantage la boule utilitaire que les
boules décoratives c'est ça plutôt la
boule utilitaires mais alors simple
pratique hygiénique par salissantes et
facile à entretenir facile d'entretenir
passé
alors là vous aurez du mal à retrouver
parce que si j'ai bien compris ce que
vous cherchez la boule l'utilitaire
facile à entretenir c'est la boule de
luxe et la boule de luxe n'est pas
facile à entretenir
voyez aujourd'hui certains il dans un
jeu ne savait pas où je pourrais trouver
des cubes par hasard
demandez la gazette du festival sinon
oui voyez vous dimanche sur l'autoroute
de l'ouest
arpajon chercher des lentilles la façon
la spécialité c'est la ricoh sur les
nantis on va c'est pas grâce aux
histoires pages on n'est pas sur
l'autoroute de l'ouest heures à quoi
qu'il en soit quand on double on
prévient qu'ils aient la famille une
famille on klaxonne j'ai pas de klaxon
pour les perdus bon j'ai donné un pot
pourquoi je n'ai pas de monnaie privée
klaxons ou pas klaxons vous rouler trop
vite je sais je sais dans mon quartier
on m'appelle le gagarine de l'asfa y
arrive et vous ne regardez jamais votre
compte j'ai pas de compteur ya pas de
compteur longer un baromètre à quoi un
baromètre du grec barousse poèmes être
en mesure de marquer mon plein pot les
biens et à quelle vitesse roulait vous
quand vous m'avez doublé a beau fixe
oui à bouffer je voulais a beau fixe
alors vous démarrez comment comme tout
le monde
un tempête et ensuite mais ensuite je
pense à variable jarril un beau fixe
on va passer la saison enfin j'espère
vous avez dont ferait un excellent oui
mais j'ai pas de [ __ ] notre fameux
laissiez pourquoi comme pour govou
l'agglo biais de vitesse ah parce que
quand même vous avez un levier dites est
évidemment fait comme on ferait ch pour
jauger les sens oui bonjour j'ai les
sens avec votre vitesse en jalles bull
dire ce n'est pas jojo ci mais j'en suis
servi pour faire les essuie glaces
salées suisse à supporter allemand non
en fait tout va changer
mais alors quand il pleut vous recevez
la pluie d'un visage à l'encan des
vosges en scaphandre et bah quand il
pleut sur le scaphandre sa move le blu
non parce que sur le hublot j'ai mis les
essuie glaces à bon rythme à autre chose
sans frein comment faites vous pour vous
arrêter quand je peux les sens ça ne
vaut pas des francs maçons pour les
freins qui font marcher une voiture non
pas pour s'arrêter sur une paix sûre
s'arrêter faut être parti pour partir
faute de l'essence mais enfin des
phrases c'est indispensable je pense à
vous me faites rire voulait briguer
marshall essence ils n'ont pas de frais
pour ce malin et intelligent
ce n'est pas un retour hic est qu'il
emmènera repas jour et alors je le vois
mes cigarettes avec ma voiture
bon écoute et après tout fait ou vous
voulez ça me regarde pas vous devez vous
demander votre camion de fromage
quelqu'un monde fromage celui que vous
conduisiez dimanche quand je les ai
doublé cette fois du fromage c'était des
frais
alors si vous voulez un conseil des cinq
mois que ce sont des formats sinon vous
aurez du mal à vous en défaire on tard
tout est vendu comme fromage ou comme
phrase comment caustique innocent pas de
facile à conduire un gros camion comme
ça toi ça se conduit toute seule pièce
vous fait dodo là je tiens le volant
soutenez-le valence fayçal valeur
pourrait vous donner le volant pour
conduire une voiture
- voilà donc ça m'a permis oui il faut
un permis pour tenir un volant moi j'ai
permis mais ce n'est pas le volant mais
alors comment conduisez-vous doit tuer
avec mon père mais pour prendre un
virage vous servez de votre permis non
je me la flèche
non oui d'accord mais ce n'est pas la
flèche qui est tournée la voiture lancée
le virage voulez que je vous dise un
vous conduisez comme un intellectuel
sous développés tout le monde ne peut
pas transporter les frais ce qui pue oui
eh ben il vaut mieux tant que berlin
insisté ban de toute façon j'ai pu
voiture je les ai perdus on est perdu
oui dans une descente dans une descente
et je tombais rap alors d'une cote alors
qu'avez vous fait voici descendu boire
c'est d'ailleurs la démonter mais alors
comme derrière elle est montée je me
sois prêté à remonter à remonter à
remonter dans la voiture et en suisse
ensuite au moment de remonter dans la
voiture
la voiture est descendu dans la montée
non dans la descente
non dans la montée enfin soyez logique
quand on descend une montée c'est que
c'est une descente sera dépenseront
l'avant de la voiture seront utiles dans
la voiture qui se trouvait à l'arrière
d'une voiture descendez de monter je
comprends rien du tout c'est pourtant
simple quand tu vas tu remontes une
compte la vraie plus haut que l'arrière
oui quand tu m'as tu redescends compte
l'arrière et plock l'avant oui alors
dans le cas présent qui nous intéressent
nos voitures descendait mais comme
l'avant était plus haut que l'arrière
elle descendait une montée voilà ah oui
ça oui ça y est oui je vois oui en
quelque sorte elle reculait comment
dites-vous
elle reculait vous n'êtes pas tout
simple vos seins un peu snob bon nom
alors qu'avaient ou frais avant jane
brain vu des bras attachés dans cette
chaussure pourquoi ces défunts enfin
quoi on n'a pas cherché à rattraper
votre voiture avec un lancer de
chaussures des femmes est fou mais
qu'est ce que vous allez faire alors
agir acheter des chaussures sans lacets
non
la gazette en huit journées entonné
[ __ ] je vous la donne j'en ai plein
mon concert quand vous regardez vous
deux transatlantiques qui rentre dans le
port à l'enjeu paraît plutôt qu'un qui
prend le large
sanvensa pas regardé
[Musique]
tiens au fait j'ai un bon jour vous
souhaitez avant de quitter sa part de ma
cousine germaine de cousine germaine ma
cousine germaine cousine germaine un
cousin germain ne se connaît pas mais
ici elizabeth may faudrait savoir céder
à bétou germaine c'est elisabeth après
midi germaine le produit germain mehdi
ma cousine germaine je produis
qu'elisabeth s'appelait germaine non
mais vous m'avez laissé entendre que
germaine sable elisabeth pas du tout
j'ai dit ma cousine germaine nous avons
eu je connaissais pas oui ce à quoi j'ai
ajouté elisabeth dont je répète c'est
elisabeth germaine sainte élisabeth
alors pourquoi me parlez-vous autre
cousine germaine pas parce que elisabeth
c'est ma cousine germaine et vos
collègues et vous elisabeth parce que
c'est son prénom prénom qui ma cousine
germaine alors germaine c'est son nom
non non non c'est robert robert cailliau
pour une femme robert sait pas plus
curieux que le nom de mon tonton qui
s'appelle comment votre montant martin
votre tata martin fafard martins et
féminin est alors alors je ne comprends
pas quand on s'appelle martin oui bien
sûr enfin écoutez si on va par là où ça
mais non tu te sens de parler au total
si on va par là ma cousine germaine
s'appelle denis robert et son mari marc
robert et maintenant que son mari mais
évidemment ce qu'elle allait épouser
bahrami faisait vous avez de tonton
pourquoi ça ferait martin qui symbolisa
bêtement germaine qu elle germé à la fin
de votre cousin robert non non non vous
n'y êtes pas du tout alors je prends
deux cousines permet de l'époque jean
germain alors comme ça tu es le bon je
vous laisse à votre cousine germaine
elisabeth germaine mais enfin non de 2
ce n'est qu'une cousine comment
s'appelle-t-elle elisabeth alors
pourquoi larbodie salon gbodossou était
d'elisabeth parce que m'avait interrompu
interrompu mois à la radio puis - avait
interrompu entre germaine elisabeth
ballon finalement la can et de moteurs
bonjour germaine ou les abris elizabeth
allons-y simplement c'est elisabeth
c'est elisabeth et votre cousine
germaine est fâché mais elle est pas
fâchée parce que nous souhaitons bonjour
alors sainte-élisabeth vous gâcher
quelque chose
non vous allez peut-être aussi dure
qu'une oreilles de sourds mieux
s'arrêter d'ailleurs moi aussi j'ai un
bon jour vous souhaitez la part de king
part de serge s'est réjoui serge
qu'elles servent aux cousins germains
je connais pas ça m'étonnerait pourquoi
c'est le frères d'elisabeth
[Musique]